- Good morning, Believe Nation!
Today's message is fight for your beliefs.
Over to you Marco Pierre White.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- Many people have condemned
me for being controversial.
I was never controversial.
As I've always said, most of my reputation
is a product of
exaggeration and ignorance.
Did I shout?
Yes, I did.
But I led from the front.
I nailed my colors to the mast.
I fought for my profession.
If you're going to be a rebel,
make sure you win.
If you're going to be a revolutionary,
then fight for what you truly believe in.
And that's all I ever did.
And the boys behind me they followed me.
- Most people don't
know what they stand for
and so they don't know
what they're fighting for.
Most people are lost
and that's why they end up following
somebody who has more certainty
who has more self-awareness than they do,
instead of living their own life.
Instead of being a leader for yourself,
you're following somebody else
who just has more confidence
and self-awareness.
You need to know what you stand for
to know what you're fighting for.
This is why I wrote the book
and not some promotional piece here.
It's super important,
is identify what is the one thing
that you will not compromise?
What is the one most
important core value to you?
Most people don't know,
and if you don't know
then how are you living a life
and running a business
with any kind of purpose?
You'll just be constantly reacting
to what other people are giving you.
You're living somebody else's life
and not your own.
And so I think that self-awareness
is one of the most important things
that you could have
not just as an entrepreneur
but as a human being.
For you to know what your one word is,
for you to know what your one single
most important core value is
that becomes the lens through
which you see the world.
Now you can proactively build a business
and proactively create a life
that reflects your most
important core value.
Now you know what to fight for.
Now you know what you're no
longer willing to accept.
Because you've always
shown these tendencies.
You always gravitated
towards this one word,
this one core value.
But it was always haphazard.
It was always when things come up.
It was always random.
And so what are the chances
that that perfect mentor
or guide or relationship
or business opportunity is
going to just fall on your lap?
It could happen but
it's a small percentage.
Where now if you purposely are setting out
to build a business and a life
around your most important core value
that percentage is going
to dramatically explode.
Now, you're no longer
willing to be around people
who don't share the values that you do.
Now you're not going to be with people
who pound down your ideas.
Who tell you all the reasons
why you're not going to be successful.
Now you're going to be
open to opportunities
and they're going to find you.
That support you in doing great things.
Most people though haven't figured it out.
Most people won't figure it out
and that's why most people
will not be great leaders.
That's why most people will
never build a great life.
That's why most people walk around
feeling like they could be
doing so much more in their life
and they're not even coming close
to reaching their potential.
Doesn't mean you have
to be down in the dumps,
doesn't mean you have to had no success.
There's lots of people
who had plenty of success
but they know that they
could be doing more.
They know that they're
nowhere close to their ceiling
and they don't know how to get there.
And they don't know what's wrong.
What's wrong is you don't
know what you stand for.
know what you're fighting for.
What's wrong is you're
just following other people
instead of being the leader
that you were meant to be.
So find your one word.
Find your single most important core value
and then you've found what
you should be fighting for.
So the question of the
day today is, I'm curious.
What is your one word?
What is the single most important thing
that you are fighting for?
I want the one word and
I want a sentence or two
as to why it really
means something to you.
Why is this so important to you?
Leave it in the comments and
we'll join in the discussion.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to David.
David, thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word.
I really really really
appreciate the support
and hope you're enjoying it.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is,
much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
Hey, Believe Nation.
Thank you so much for watching.
If you want to learn
more about this subject,
get a little bit deeper on it.
I'm going to share some extra bonus clips
that I hope you'll enjoy.
- And what I'm telling artists
is you got to have balls
and got to let these guys know.
If you're a DJ be DJ.
If you're a radio personality,
be a radio personality
and nothing more.
We make the music that allows them
to have a voice on the radio.
And they took control and try to say,
say that they have all the power
and going to dictate what we have to do.
I spoke out against it.
So they got a dummy to go up there
and be a dummy on the radio
and speak on their
behalf and talk about me.
And it's really unfortunate
'cause they're using him
and he's not even a part of my fight.
My fight is a big fight.
My fight is against any power structure
that's going to try to hold
back the freedom of speech.
And that fight ain't over yet.
- Amazed at how few people
have a belief system.
What do they actually believe in?
And, yeah, it's okay to offend you guys.
90% of you will do what's expected of you
as opposed to what you want to do.
And I even, when I come
to an event like this say
why am I here?
Why would I even bother to take
an hour of my valuable time?
(audience laughing)
No, it's true.
I have to have a purpose.
My goal is very simple.
If I can convert one of you.
There's probably 400, 500 people here.
If I can convert one of
you to follow your belief
and have the guts to follow your belief,
I'll think of the hour as well spent.
So, I would say, what am
I trying to do and why?
I don't speak because somebody will write
nice things about it.
I always sort of have a purpose,
but I have a belief system.
And most people, even
successful companies,
and I have big beef with Fortune 500 CEOs
I can talk about.
There's very little leadership there,
don't have an internal compass
of what they believe in.
It's what do others expect.
You know when I graduated, I
went into entrepreneurship.
Nobody went into entrepreneurship
out of the business school.
And people said why wouldn't you
work for Goldman or McKinsey?
And I said why would you?
I couldn't fathom why you
would want to do that job.
Right? I still can't, by the way.
(audience laughing)
For those of you going to those places,
and I'm sure there's plenty,
I'm probably not the right
person to talk to you.
I frankly don't even care to talk to you.
All of you others.
(audience laughing)
I think there's something
wrong with anybody
who fundamentally wants to go work for
one of the consultants or
the investment banks today
and there's probably,
they don't understand how
the world is going to work
in the future.
But my point again is,
have a belief system.
Follow that compass.
And I'm overstating it a bit.
So there may be some hope
for those of you going there.
But it's only a little
bit of an exaggeration.
Let me go back to this
issue of Fortune 500 CEOs.
I've talked to many over the years.
If a New York Times
writer writes an article,
they want to change their
strategy, they want to respond.
How silly is that, that some English major
who's never had a business job
can determine the strategy
of a Fortune 500 company?
Why? Because they care
about what's written
not what their belief system is.
Do you know what Elon Musk
would say to that writer?
Go get a real job.
What Jeff Bezos would say?
That's leadership.
Having a belief system.
Knowing what's driving
you to do what you do.
Not you're fitting in to
do career enhancement.
Or, making it look good to somebody else
whether it's to your
friends, or to your boss,
or to shareholders.
And frankly, you look at all the companies
that are languishing in the Valley,
the older companies.
They generally don't have a belief system.
They're generally trying to
meet some quarterly target,
without saying, here's
how we will be different
and here's how we'll do it.
Apple did languish for 10, 15 years,
and then Steve Jobs came
in with a point of view,
and created the most valuable
company in the world.
He did irrational things.
If you go back to January of 2007,
January 1, everybody was saying
nobody wants a phone without a keyboard.
Nobody wants a phone that costs $699.
I can go on with the litany.
Those were all English
majors writing articles.
I have this beef against English majors
(audience laughing)
Not all English majors are bad
but the majority of them
at Stanford are undirected
and don't have a goal or a purpose.
(audience laughing)
Sorry.
And that's not to say,
among them there isn't 20%
that are really good.
They just didn't get the right guidance
and ended up in the wrong place.
(audience laughing)
I like purposeful education.